We learned from a very early age to make
our sense of self worth conditional upon
some kind of external criteria which can
be judged by others because of this,
self compassionate becomes a challenge
because self compassion requires a
natural ability on your part to be able
to deal with your failures as well as
success with understanding,
acceptance and kindness.
The problem that I see with the self
esteem movement particularly is that
self esteem movement,
again,
you know,
kind of plays into this tendency to make
your sense of worth conditional upon
what you achieve.
Uh,
and,
and inevitably that involves comparison
with others.
And,
and you know,
there's also a moral problem there
because in order to boost yourself as
team,
sometimes you need to put down in your
mind the self compassion doesn't require
any of that.
What self compassion is suggesting is
that you should be able to do the same
thing that you normally do to someone
that you can towards yourself.
And the beauty of that is that once you
have that kind of ability to relate to
your own situation,
situation with kindness,
it creates a kind of a reservoir of
strength and resilience so that you have
planted to draw from.
Because otherwise,
if your compassion has always other
directed and you do not take care of
your own needs and your own wellbeing,
at some point,
this kind of leads to compassion
fatigue.
And even in some cases when the
relationship does not work and when
there is not enough recognition from
coming from the other,
the recipient side,
you might even feel betrayed and let
down and used and ultimately even
feeling bitterness.
So having a greater base of self
compassion really buffers against all of
these potentially negative consequences
of being always too much other focused.